this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description get 20% off the annual
subscription if there's one word you
associate with Apple the culmination of
every commercial product feature and
perfectly rehearsed keynote the company
would like it to be privacy anyone can
use the word just as I can put a Tesla
bumper sticker on my Hummer but only
Apple has the business model to prove it
and it certainly takes every opportunity
to remind us in 2016 when the FBI
demanded it create a special backdoor
Tim Cook personally and very publicly
refused saying it would undermine the
very freedoms and Liberty our government
is meant to protect it was one of the
highest profile riskiest and most
controversial debates over privacy in
recent times but ultimately whether you
think for profit or on principle it
fought the government and won that same
year on the other side of the world
China passed the cybersecurity law
requiring that Apple store Chinese a
cloud data inside the country and
prompting fear that the government could
access it for surveillance this time
though no letter to customers no
principled stand no long protracted
fight with 20% of its sales and most of
its manufacturing in China Apple has
little choice but to comply censoring
apps podcasts and services in the
world's largest country but as risks
grow and strategic calculations change
will this tension ever reach a boiling
point will there come a day when either
by choice or force Apple leaves the
country altogether
every year Apple faces an impossible
task to source the materials for
assemble deliver and meet the demand for
millions of new iPhones in total secrecy
the insane scale of the device is both
its biggest blessing and its biggest
curse the single most expensive
component of the iPhone for example is
thought to be the OLED screen at around
$110 per unit if Samsung increased the
price of that one part by just $5 it
would cost Apple an extra billion
dollars over 200 million devices the
previous generation 2013 Mac Pro was
assembled in Austin Texas but only
because of its relatively low demand the
iPhone simply doesn't have that luxury
the vast majority of Apple products
therefore are assembled by contract
manufacturers like Foxconn Pegatron and
Wistrom in China although not contrary
to popular thinking strictly because of
cost average monthly wages in China have
more than doubled from 449 u.s. dollars
in 2010 to nearly a thousand in 2018
that's about the same as many European
countries like Latvia Lithuania and
Croatia and far higher than other South
and Southeast Asian countries like the
Philippines and Vietnam where companies
like Nike Adidas and Under Armour have
moved much of their production but while
makers of clothing can for the most part
hire the cheapest hands Apple and
companies like it have to be a bit more
selective what China has more than any
other country are massive amounts of
technically skilled workers in highly
concentrated areas on demand here
factories are more cities than buildings
when one manufacturer of electronics
needed to quickly increase production to
keep up with demand it was able to hire
35,000 workers in under 6 weeks it's
this flexibility that allows Apple to
rapidly scale up production in the
summer months leading up to the release
of a new iPhone altogether about a
million and a half Chinese are involved
in assembling Apple products and another
two and a half million Chinese
developers create iOS
but even before assembly Apple relies
heavily on Chinese materials everything
from cameras to speakers motors and
batteries are made with 17 elements
called lanthanides or rare earth metals
and despite their name they aren't that
hard to find there are significant
reserves in Brazil Vietnam Russia and
India having and being willing to use
them though are two very different
things
measured by actual production China has
a near monopoly generating 70% of the
world's supply 120,000 metric tonnes a
year to second place Australia's 20,000
the problem is that although abundant
only in a few areas are these metals
clustered in high enough concentrations
to justify mining them and even then
they're an absolute headache to deal
with because they bond so easily with
other compounds and minerals after
mining they have to be chemically
separated often from radioactive and
carcinogenic materials processing one
tonne of rare earths may generate 2,000
tons of toxic waste in other words it's
expensive time-consuming and really bad
for the environment from roughly 1965 to
85 over half of the world supply came
from a single source in California
called the Mountain Pass mine then
around 2000 it was shut down for
environmental reasons at the same time
China realized their strategic value and
took the golden opportunity they had
just been given to dominate the entire
industry should China ever withhold them
for political leverage it would at least
temporarily devastate the US military
and in the process American companies
China's President Xi Jingping has hinted
at this possibility by visiting a rare
earth mine during the trade war and the
supply chain is only the first of
Apple's challenges the other is the
consumer markets under Tim Cook China
has been a major focus of the company
launching a dual-sim version of the
iPhone QR code support and localized
features like improvements to Cantonese
typing it's also leaned into its
cultural preferences offering a special
red edition of the eye
phone and raising prices which helps it
be seen as more of a luxury product and
for the most part it's worked the year
it was introduced the iPhone 10 was the
most popular phone in China and the
country became as big a market for Apple
as all of Europe combined but it's also
seen the risks as Chinese economic
growth slowed so did Apple's success and
it now finds itself caught in the
crossfire of us-china tensions the same
conspicuous design which made the iPhone
a status symbol becomes a liability
during times of increased nationalism
when China's government plays
anti-american propaganda films and
hallways ban is perceived as protecting
weaker American competitors owning an
iPhone can become embarrassing according
to Goldman Sachs a retaliatory ban could
lose Apple almost 1/3 of its overall
profits of course interdependence is a
two-way street
Apple also contributes an estimated 24
billion u.s. dollars a year to China's
economy it's not unless things get
significantly worse in China's best
interests to push out Apple completely
but it is in its best interest to keep
pushing the boundaries by exerting as
much control over Western companies like
Apple as possible if Apple will ban VPNs
censor dissenting apps and move iCloud
data on its orders there's no reason to
think it'll stop there the idea that
Apple would give up on one of its most
important sources of revenue is almost
unthinkable but that's exactly why China
can ask so much of it at some point the
things that individually wouldn't be
reason enough for Apple to leave China
slowing economic growth tariffs
censorship data storage laws competitors
like Huawei and WeChat and poor respect
for intellectual property together may
hit a critical mass that Apple will no
longer tolerate in the US Tim Cook can
persuade the public and successfully
hold back the FBI in China though it's
all-or-nothing
with every demand Apple has to decide
whether saying no is worth losing 20
percent of its revenue and perhaps even
the most important part of its supply
chain in 2010 Google did just that after
years of following China's censorship
rules it was ultimately a
straw that broke the camel's back Google
noticed the Gmail accounts of human
rights activists were being hacked into
thus far Tim Cook has always preferred
to engage unlike other tech CEOs for
example he continues taking meetings
with the US president despite
disagreeing on many issues Apple argues
better it stay in China than cede the
market to a more questionable competitor
or someone who doesn't minimize the
amount of data they collect in the first
place in the meantime it's preparing for
the worst
Pegatron is investing in production
sites in Indonesia while Foxconn and
Western look to India in 1909 Norman
Angell
wrote the great illusion for which he
received a Nobel Peace Prize in it he
argued the economies of the world were
so connected and so dependent on one
another that the cost of conflict would
simply be too great States he said now
had too much to lose from going to war
he was right and so is anyone who
dismisses conflict between China and
Apple strategically financially
logically speaking it would be foolish
for either one to give up the economic
benefits and yet five years after the
great illusion was published began one
of the most deadly conflicts and history
circumstances can change in an instant
and even the most profitable company on
earth is vulnerable likewise in 10 20 30
years the programming languages that are
relevant today may no longer be and
that's why instead of having you
memorize code brilliant explains the big
ideas behind it in their new course
called computer science essentials like
all of brilliance courses on math
puzzles science and logic it teaches
with examples pretty graphics and easily
understood language you can learn
science with pool logic with puzzles and
geometry with art for example there are
also quick fun daily challenges you can
use the link in the description to start
learning for free and the first 200
people will get 20% off the annual
premium subscription so you can view all
the daily challenges and unlock dozens
of problem-solving courses
thanks again to brilliant NTU for
watching this video
you